Three reasons why we should
continue using nuclear energy.
One Nuclear Energy Saves lives in 2013
a study conducted by NASA found that
nuclear energy has prevented
around 1.8 million deaths,
even if you include the death
tolls from Chernobyl and Fukushima.
Nuclear energy ranks last in
death per energy units produced.
While nuclear waste is really toxic,
it's usually stored somewhere while the
toxic byproducts of fossil fuels are
pumped into the air.
We breathe every day.
So just by reducing the
amount of fossil fuels burned.
Countless cases of cancer or lung disease
and accidents in coal mines have been
avoided.
If we can choose between lots of dangerous
stuff being put into a deep hole and
lots and lots and lots of dangerous
stuff being pumped into the atmosphere.
The former seems more logical.
Nuclear energy feels way more dangerous
though single catastrophic events burned
into our memory while coal
and oil kills sign and date,
it's like the death rate
of flying versus driving.
Even in the best case scenario,
it would take at least 40 years to
switch to 100% renewable energy.
So for as long as we
continue using fossil fuels,
nuclear energy will save way more lives
than it destroys to nuclear energy
reduces co two emissions.
Nuclear energy is arguably way less
harmful to the environment in terms of
climate change than fossil fuels.
Our main source of energy since 1976
about 64 gigatons of greenhouse gas
emissions have not been pumped out thanks
to nuclear energy and by the mid 21st
century that could amount to an
additional 80 to 240 gigatons.
Humanity's energy consumption is raising
steadily according to u s government
projections,
China alone will add the equivalent of
a new 600 megawatt coal plant every 10
days for the next 10 years. China
already burns 4 billion tons of coal.
The chair coal is cheap,
relatively abundant and easy to get to.
So it's not likely that humanity will
stop using it soon when nuclear energy
might be the only way of dampening the
effects of climate change and preventing
a catastrophic manmade global warming
compared to the other things we do.
Nuclear energy is relatively clean,
so even if it is a good idea to
quit nuclear energy longterm,
it might be a good solution for the
next hundred years or so compared to the
alternatives.
Three new technologies,
maybe technology will solve the problem
of nuclear waste and dangerous power
plants.
The nuclear reactors we've used so far
are mostly outdated technology because
nuclear innovation stopped in the 1970s
there are models like the ethereum
reactor that could solve the problem
altogether. Thorim as abundant, ready,
hard to turn into nuclear weapons and
up to two orders of magnitude less
wasteful than current nuclear reactors.
The waste material might also be only
dangerous for a few hundred years.
In contrast to a couple of thousand years,
one ton of Thor IOM is estimated to
provide the same amount of energy as 200
tons of uranium,
all 3.5 million tons of coal.
So while we cannot know for
sure if alternative nuclear
technology will keep its
promises,
shouldn't we at least do more research
before we forego an opportunity to solve
lots of humanities current problems?
It might not be an easy challenge,
but that hasn't stopped us before.
So should we use nuclear energy?
There are risks involved in any great
human endeavor and we have to make an
informed decision rather
than rely on gut feeling.
If you want to hear the other side of
the argument or a short introduction to
nuclear energy, click here.
Our channel has a new sponsor,
audible.com if you use the
URL audible.com/nutshell
you can get a free audio
book and support our channel.
Producing our videos takes a lot of time
and we fill a lot of us by listening to
audiobooks for radio entertaining
book we recommend into thin air by Jon
Krakauer. He's a great writer and the
story is really absorbing and true.
Go to audible.com/nutshell
to get the book for free.
Thanks a lot to audible for supporting
our channel and to you for watching.